Problem 41.
Use the histogram below
to answer the
question that follows.
Here's our histogram.
Two six-sided number cubes.
They sound suspiciously
like regular dice.
Two six-sided number
cubes are rolled
simultaneously 10 times.
So it's like you're rolling
two dice 10 times.
The sums are recorded in the
histogram shown above.
So when you look at what's on
top of your dice, and you add
them up, and then they recorded
the frequency of the
different sums. Which of the
following statements can be
inferred from the histogram?
So the first one says the
mean is less than
the median by 1/10.
The mean-- OK, so they're
comparing the mean and the
median in every one
of these choices.
So we can actually look at this
histogram and figure out
all of the results
that happened.
So the sum, we got
3 three times.
So we got three 3's, 3, 3, 3.
We got one 4.
We got three 5's, right?
5 had a frequency of
3, so 5, 5, 5.
And then we had no 6's.
And then we had three
7's, 7, 7, 7.
So the median is easy
to figure out.
The median is literally just
the middle number.
So how many do we have here?
We have 1, 2, 3, 4,
5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10.
So the middle number is going--
or the middle two
numbers, because it's an even,
and if they're not the same
number, we're going to have
to take the average.
So what's the middle number?
If we have 4 on this side, and
4 on this side, the middle
numbers-- right, because we have
an even data center, 5.
So the median here
is equal to 5.
Now, the mean is going to take
a little bit of more
mathematics.
We're going to have to sum up
all of our results, and then
divide by the total of data
points there are.
Well, actually I should have
known that there are 10 data
points, we're going
to divide by 10.
So what's the sum?
It's 3 times 3.
So this is 9 plus 4, plus 5
times 3-- you have 5 times 3
here, which is 15-- plus
7 times 3, which is 21.
So 9 plus 4 is 13,
plus 15, plus 21.
This is 13 plus 15
is 28, plus 21.
28 plus 21 is 49.
And if we have to divide that by
10, we get an average-- so
if you divide it by 10, because
we have 10 data
points, the average is going
to be equal to 4.9.
So our average is 4.9
Our median is 5.
So our average is 1/10
less than our median.
Or when I say average,
I should say mean.
But it tends to mean, you know,
when people say average,
they tend to mean the mean.
Our mean, where we just added
up all the data points and
divided by 10, is 1/10
less than the median.
So let's see, the mean is less
than the median by 1/10.
That looks right.
Our mean is less than
the median by 1/10.
Choice A.
Problem 42.
Use the graph below to answer
the question that follows.
Distribution of test scores.
All right.
The graph above shows the
distribution of scores on a
test with possible scores of
10, 20, 30, 40, 50, and 60.
Those are the only
possible scores.
Maybe there were only six
questions on the exam.
Well, yeah, sure.
The minimum passing
score was 40.
So this is the minimum
passing score.
You have to get at least
a 40 to pass.
20 girls and 20 boys took the
test. The percentage of girls
passing the test was how much
greater than the percentage of
boys passing the test?
All right.
So let's see how many girls
passed the test. So this
dotted graph is the girls.
So 5 got a 40, so
those passed.
They just barely passed.
So you had those 5
girls get a 40.
Then you had another
6 girls get a 50.
So you have another 6 girls get
a 50, and you had another
4 girls get a 60, plus 4.
So that's how many
girls passed.
So that's 5 plus 6 is 11, plus
4 is 15 girls passed.
There were a total of 20 girls,
so 15 out of 20, or,
you could think of
that as 75%.
If you divide 15 by 20, that's
the same thing as 3/4, or 75%
of girls passed.
Now let's do the boys.
And I'll do it in stereotypical
colors, the boys in blue.
Once again, they have to get
at least a 40 to pass.
So 6 boys just barely
passed, got the 40.
Then 3 boys got a 50.
They passed.
Plus 2 boys got a
60, they passed.
So total of 6 plus 3, plus
2 is 11 boys passed.
11 out of 20 is the same
thing as what?
That's 55%.
If you multiply the numerator
and the denominator by 5, you
get 55 over 100.
So this is equal to 55%
of the boys passed.
Now, what did they ask us?
I forgot already.
The percentage of girls passing
the test was how much
greater than the percentage
of boys passing the test?
So 75% is how much
greater than 55%?
Well 75% minus 55%,
that's 20%.
The girls' percentage is 20%
larger than the boys'
percentage.
The percentage of girls passing
the test was how much
greater than the percentage of
boys passing the test. Right.
It's 20 percentage
points greater.
Next question.
43.
Use the table below to answer
the question-- oh, I think
I've learned that.
A marketing company conducted
a survey to determine
milkshake flavor preferences
among five
different age groups.
These are the different
age groups.
This is the different options,
I guess, on milkshakes.
Based on the data in the table,
what is the probability
that a randomly chosen
35-year-old customer will
prefer a strawberry-flavored
milkshake?
So a randomly chosen
35-year-old, that puts us in
this bucket, right here,
30- to 39-year-olds.
So if they can be described by
the data that we've collected
already, the probability is
the same ratio of the data
sample we've collected that
actually liked-- what was
it?-- strawberry-flavored
milkshakes.
So in that age group, how many
total people did we survey?
We surveyed 8 plus 14 is 22.
22 plus 12 is 34.
We surveyed 34 people in this
age group, and how many of
them liked strawberry
milkshakes?
Well 12 of them did.
12 out of 34 30- to 39-year-olds
liked strawberry
milkshakes.
So, the probability, if we use
that as our data, that a
random 30- to 39-year-old will
like strawberry milkshakes is
12 over 34, or if we reduce
this, that's 6 over 17.
Just divide the numerator and
the denominator by 2.
And that is D.
Good thing that that was one
of the answer choices, D.
Problem 44.
A child has a set of blocks,
4 of which are square.
5 are round.
And 6 are triangular.
The child randomly picks a block
from the set and gives
it to his sister.
The child then randomly picks
one more block, so he didn't
put that block back in.
That's very important--
that first block.
What is the probability that the
first block was round and
the second block
was triangular?
So the probability the
first block is round.
How may total blocks do we
have to start off with?
We have 15, right?
4 plus 6 is 10, plus 5 is 15.
So we started off
with 15 blocks.
And what is the probability that
the first block is round?
Well 5 of them are round,
so there's a 5 over 15
probability.
So this is the probability
that first is
round, right there.
And now, what is the probably
that the second block is
triangular?
Now, remember, we no longer have
15 blocks in the pile.
Now, he's taken one
of the blocks and
given it to his sister.
So now we're choosing
out of 14 blocks.
And we're also-- and this is an
and-- so we're assuming--
so what is the probability
that the second block is
triangular given that the first
block was a circle?
So we assume that we still have
our full contingency of 6
triangles there, that that
wasn't picked our first time.
So the probability that the
second block is triangular--
there are 6 triangles, there are
6 triangles out of the 14
blocks left.
So our answer is going to be 5
over 15, which is the same
thing as 1/3, times 6 over 14 is
the same thing as 3 over 7,
which is the same thing
as 1 over 7.
And that is choice C.
Problem 45.
Use the spinner below
to answer the
question that follows.
OK, there's our spinner.
The host of a party tells her
guests that every time the
spinner above lands on the
section labeled fruit basket--
that's the section labeled fruit
basket-- a guest will
win a large basket of fruit.
If the 180 guests at the party
each spin the spinner once,
what is the best estimate of
the number of fruit baskets
that the host will
be giving away?
So let's see, we have,
1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
They look about equal, so
you have 5 equal pies.
So it looks like there's a 0.2,
or 20% chance, of getting
fruit baskets.
So each person can almost
pretend like they get 0.2 of a
fruit basket.
So they have 0.2, or maybe I'd
say they have a 1/5 chance,
and then you have 180 of those
people, so times 180.
I could have multiplied
this times 180.
This would be the expected
value, the expected number of
fruit baskets I'm going
to give away.
So what's 1/5 times 180?
Or well, how many times
does 5 go into 180?
5 goes into 18 three times.
3 times 5 is 15.
18 minus 15 is 3.
30, 36 times.
So I would expect to give
away 36 baskets.